Oswald cobblepot takes center stage in
the penguin but let's be honest we want
to see more villains more of the Arkham
and Wayne's family's history and High
Caliber umbrellas perhaps one of
Gotham's most iconic locations the
Iceberg Lounge offers the criminals of
Gotham City a place to relax and rub
elbows with their crooked cohorts while
the lounge isn't expressly a villains
only Club the atmosphere and clientele
to the business caters to is
unmistakable thus in large part thanks
to its owner and operator Oswald
cobblepot the Batman depicts the Iceberg
Lounge as a club in the hearts of Gotham
populated by the city's most influential
and corrupt politicians in DC Comics law
the Iceberg Lounge is typically utilize
at the front for the Penguins nefarious
criminal activities showing how the
penguin came to own and operate such an
establishment in the world of the Batman
would help to further establish the
Penguin's character and while it's not a
story that's worth dedicating an entire
series to a flashback in the narrative
to Mark the occasion would be enough to
do the lounge Justice
criminals aren't born they're made that
said that Batman portrays us as a sleazy
weasel fans expect him to be as he
already commands whole gangs of armed
thugs the penguin might just show us how
Oz established the position he enjoys in
the Batman of course there's something
else we all want to know will the
penguin seize power following Carmine
Falcone's death and the destruction
brought upon Gotham City by The Riddler
at the end of the film we see the
penguin gazing out at the city
contemplating its future as a feared
gangster clearly now is the time to take
control but will he succeed
you better watch it
you know my reputation yeah I do
in DC Comics law Oswald cobblepot is
subject to a depressing backstory in
most iterations of the character he has
finally bullied amongst for his stature
sometimes he was even given the name
penguin by his abusers and when he
finally becomes angry enough to
furiously retaliate he decides to own
the name reclaiming it as a fearsome
symbol other versions of his history
tell a tale of the umbrellancing and
harsh realities of leading and
impoverished life claiming that oddsa's
family lost everything after his father
died of a pneumonia-like illness brought
on by inclement weather Oswald later
takes up a life of crime to rise out of
the squalor in which he has lived for so
long there are plenty of differing
versions of Oz's origin for the penguin
to choose from one thing that is always
true though is that Gotham's criminals
don't become gangsters because they
enjoyed cushy lives some things steered
the penguin in this direction and is a
path worth retreading in the upcoming
series it might even earn him a little
sympathy from viewers the Penguin's most
interesting relationship in the Batman
is the one that he enjoyed with Carmine
Falcon as demonstrates his loyalty to
Carmine when he bitterly rejects the
idea that he would ever become a rat
even if it were to Ward a rival as he
understands that Carmine Falcone would
have his head obviously the irony of
this later becomes quite clear still
ozin Falcone obviously had an unspoken
partnership one that stretched back far
before the events of the Batman and
while Carmine Falcone held the most
power in Gotham's criminal underbelly
the penguin wasn't far behind what led
to his alliance with Carmine Falcone and
why was he so loyal to the mafia head
honcho well Carmine might be dead in the
present day dialogue or flashbacks might
serve to flesh out the fascinating
relationship between them the penguin of
the Batman is a visually striking foe
the Prosthetics and makeup are so well
done in fact that Oz looks like an
entirely different man than the
clean-cut Irish actor we know underneath
in Universe it's clear that the penguin
has seen better days there is noticeable
scarring all along his face indicating
that us has earned his stripes as a
feared gangster but what exactly
happened how did the penguin get those
scars the baby tied to his origin as a
feared monster there's certainly an
argument that's like the Joker from
Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight
keeping the Scar's Origins are known as
to the Penguins Mystique as a character
hardened by the streets
however the penguin is a very different
type of character than the Joker one who
might benefit from some further
backstory hopefully the penguin reveals
the truth behind that rugged mug the
Batman Begins shortly after the city's
major bursts of salmaroni's drug
operations the headline news can be seen
framed on the wall of the mayor's Abode
as a riddler quietly stalks him in the
film's opening scene quickly though we
learned that the drug bust was a facade
when Batman follows a penguin in an
effort to identify him as a potential
rat he learns that production is Alive
and Well in other words a drug bust was
all a Big Show by Gotham's most corrupt
politicians and salmaroni was the full
guy for the display Carmine Falcone the
Penguin and their underling subsequently
took over moroni's operation Clancy
Brown is set to play salmaroni in the
Penguin and it's likely the character
will have a few things to say about his
relationship with the late Carmine
Falcone as well as the criminals who
worked for him the Falcon and Moroni
families are often portrayed as major
players in Gotham City's criminal
underworld having often weighs war
against one another throughout the
city's turbulence comic book history
this could be good ground to cover in
the penguin in the third Act of the
Batman The Riddler partially succeeds in
his goals bringing Devastation to Gotham
and nearly assassinating the city's new
mayor Batman and Jim Gordon foil the
assassination attempt but the city is
torn apart by flooding after the Riddler
blows open the sea wall seeing the news
cycle from his salanakam The Riddler
becomes visibly upset over Batman's
victory over his underlings one Shady
character however offers a riddler a
little bit of comfort
the next
you're a clown at this stage we all know
that the neighboring cellmate is none
other than the Joker played by Barry
kyogen since the Joker is already in
Arkham fans want to know how exactly did
he get there has he already gone
full-blown Joker Matt Reeves stated that
the character is definitely in the
proto-joker stage and isn't quite yet
the villain we all know and love but
something must have occurred to London
menaka perhaps the Penguin series might
offer a few hints regarding Joker's
previous encounters with the Batman
speaking of which in the opening moments
of the film The Batman offers a brief
Glimpse at all the criminals of Gotham
see the Kate's Crusader as the bat
signal lights up the night sky an array
of robbers and vandals are seen quaking
in their boots at the very sight of the
dark Michael jokino's swelling musical
score only emphasizes that dread
criminals begin to feel when they think
Batman might be hot on their heels with
the penguin focused solely on the
penguin it's likely we won't see much of
Batman if anything at all if we do it
may be no more than a few shadowy
glimpses of the character or a handful
of of quick and flashy action sequences
that don't reveal much regardless it
would be a welcome change in perspective
to see the Penguin and his goons face
down the threat of the Batman a larger
than life monster who seems to stalk
every shadow in Gotham in the comic
books The Penguin often has his trusty
trick umbrella at the ready in most
cases the umbrella doubles as a firearm
so he can surprise his Target should the
occasion arise in the Batman Oz is only
briefly seen with an umbrella at the
mayor's funeral this may have been just
an ordinary umbrella but it could
equally have concealed a deadly weapon
although you probably shouldn't expect
much more than that while the Penguin's
umbrella can perform a multitude of
functions in the comics the more
grounded reality in which Matt Reeves
has based his Batman World limits the
use of a cartoonish trick umbrella if it
appears at all it's likely to hide a
firearm at most but that doesn't mean it
wouldn't be fun to see but Batman did a
great job of providing fans with
evidence at a much bigger Gotham lies
just outside the bounds of the main
narrative many of these Easter eggs hug
back to the comics for example when we
saw a reference to Edward Elliott the
man who in comic book law helped
modernize Gotham City in the Batman he
is the reporter who was slain by Carmine
Falcone as a favor for Thomas Wayne this
suggests that we may be looking at a
potential host story line for future
sequels since in the comics Elliot's
great great grandson becomes a villain
known by that name the penguin has an
even better chance to highlight famous
DC Comics characters in Batman's World
however with D.A Gil Coulson out of the
picture it's entirely possible that we
could see Harvey Dent enter the race for
district attorney
even about
we might even get to see some more of
Jim Gordon's family however you cut it
there are many opportunities for the
penguin to highlight or tease characters
from Batman's long history Gotham City
is its own character in the world of the
Batman the city is Rich with lavish
creepy and seedy locales many of which
call back to the Caped Crusaders comic
book history but the penguin could take
things further since a joker has already
made his entrance into this version of
Gotham perhaps we'll see ace chemicals
the famous chemical plant where he
became the clown Prince of Crime
meanwhile if Matt Reeves and Company one
day decide to bring the Boy Wonder into
the mix Hayley's circus will be a fine
reference for the penguin to make
meanwhile us is sure to recruit some of
the city's most hardened criminals for
his attempt to take control of Gotham
perhaps a visit to Blackgate
Penitentiary is in order clearly there
are plenty of opportunities for the
penguin to broaden the scope of the city
that the Batman brought to life in the
Batman we learn a little bit about
Gotham's most prominent families the
Wayne's and the arkhams both families
helped establish Gotham City while
Arkham's State Hospital is obviously
named after the latter family even more
interesting however is that Martha Wayne
actually belonged to the Arkham family
before marrying Thomas Wayne while
Thomas Wayne targeted a reporter for
potentially unleashing damaging material
on Martha's mental condition to the
public it's unknown if there was more
that Thomas hoped to protect of course
it's later revealed that Thomas never
had any intention for Carmine Falcone to
kill the man and felt intense skills
when he found out what happened he
resolved to go report everything to the
authorities but was killed before he
could do so it's a tantalizing story and
one that the penguin May expand further
there isn't a shadow of a doubt that at
some points the penguin will seize power
in Gotham's criminal underworld once he
claims a late Carmine Falcone's Throne
however what will he do next how does he
plan to expand his Empire in a Gotham
now emboldened by the heroism of Batman
the penguin is going to have to
establish his power through fear since
its allies at City Hall are likely no
more all of this of course means that
Batman will no doubt take notice of the
penguin does Oz intend believe a
campaign to bring him down either way
the penguin is going to have to deal
with the Batman in the future and it'll
be interesting to see if the HBO series
starts us down the road to that Showdown
foreign
[Music]